[موسيقى]
المافيا الرابعه في ترتيب المافيات
الايطاليه تواصل سيرها في نهج الصامت وعدم
لفت الانتباه لكن مسدسات عناصرها تخرق هذا
الصمت كل حين مافيا فوجا غير معروفه لكنها
شديده العنف واطلقت جرس الانذار في منطقه
بوليا الجنوبيه وكامل ايطاليا بعد
محاولاتها اعاده ترسيخ نفوذها
اقترب مني هؤلاء الاشخاص وبداوا يقولون
انني يجب ان ادفع اما ان ادفع او سيحدث لي
شيء سيء
بمسدس مصوب للراس تستميل مافيا فوجاء
المستضعفين من التجاره وتخضع ذوي الثروات
وتفرض عليهم ما يشبه الايتاوات محاوله
ابتزاز متكرره وحرائق واضرار بالمحاصيل
والممتلكات تنتهي غالبا بالموافقه الجبريه
يتدخل رئيس بتريلا ويسحب مسدسا ويوجهه نحو
ويقول اما ان تدفع 150 الف يورو سنويا او
ستواجه انت وعائلتك اسوا مشاكل حياتك
تمارس انشطتها منذ ثلاثه عقود وتعزز
سيطرتها عبر مجموعه متنوعه الاختصاصات
بينها تهريب المخدرات والسرقه والابتزاز
وعمليات السطو المسلح وصولا الى تفجيرات
ليليه لواجهات المحلات والسيارات بهدف
اقناع اصحاب المتاجر المترددين بالدفع
فيما احدث اخطارها يتمثل باختراق المؤسسات
العامه
انها مافي عنيفه عدوانيه للغايه واليوم
اصبحت اكثر تطورا تطلق النار بشكل اقل
وتحاول اتباع استراتيجيه الصمت وعدم لفت
الانتباه
مقاطعه فوجا تمتلك الثالثه اعلى معدل
جرائم قتل في ايطاليا وسجلت سته عشره
جريمه العام الماضي خمس منها ارتبطت
بالمافيا وما قيل انه تصفيه حساباته ووفق
الشرطه المدينه فان تغلب السكان على
مخاوفهم واللجوء لمراكز الامن هو السبيل
الوحيد لاضعافها خصوصا مع ازدياد الحملات
القمعيه التي تستهدفها وتعتقل افرادها